and the wombles of wimbledon common to
spread their environmental message at
cop 26.
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the uk's only
a climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions
now in 2015 leaders and scientists from
around the world gathered to sign the
paris agreement and since then there has
been a 76 reduction in proposed coal
power construction that's according to a
new report by climate group e3g and with
the consumption of thermal coal power
generation now that is thought to
account for a fifth of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions the cop 26
climate summit will hope to continue
that trend so let's take a closer look
now at the research well there has been
a huge reduction in proposed coal power
76
since the negotiation of that paris
agreement in 2015. the united nations
secretary general antonio guterres has
called for no new coal by 2021 which 42
countries are the ones you can see here
in dark blue they have already committed
to that including the uk with a further
41 including the united states now in a
position to commit to no new coal plans
after cancelling power plants that were
previously planned
but these 37 countries are pressing
ahead with constructing new coal
projects but it's mainly just these six
countries
they're responsible for 82 of the
remaining global pipeline of
pre-construction projects with china
accounting for more than half of that
total well we can get more now on this
from sky's europe correspondent michelle
clifford evening michelle it's pretty
clear that summits can have a big impact
but you can really see the importance of
getting those big countries like china
on board
yeah very much though and that is going
to be uh the big challenge but let's
look at the positive uh to start the
report does make uh for positive reading
many nations going in the right
direction on this issue as you mentioned
something like three quarters of future
coal projects actually scrapped since
the paris climate
agreement and of course this report
comes at a very important
point ahead of the cup 26 climate change
conference the president of that
conference alex sharma had said that um
he wants to consign coal uh to the past
but at that conference they are going to
be looking at what the big issues are or
where the big issues are and you
mentioned china china responsible for
over 50 percent of future coal uh
projects in fact the report says as you
mentioned if six countries uh china
india vietnam indonesia turkey and
bangladesh scrapped their future uh coal
projects that would account for over 80
percent of future plans so um clearly uh
significance and the reason why it is uh
incredibly important is because of
course coal is one of the biggest
emitters of uh carbon uh emissions and
there is this pledge to stop the rising
global temperatures in the future but i
should add
that the eu itself needs to
look inside many countries sky news uh
in recent months has been to germany
where there's a massive uh construction
of a coal project affecting homes and
villages sky also went to poland heavily
reliant on coal uh too so there is a
global issue uh but the european union
certainly has issues uh to look at and
i'm sure they're going to be addressed
at the cop 26 conference yeah the stakes
are high aren't they michelle thank you
well let's have a look now at our data
dashboard and the real-time power mix
between renewables and fossil fuel
energy in this country right now well as
you can see renewables they're coming in
at 27
and fossil fuels including of course
coal is at 56 further down that
dashboard this is the co2 emissions
globally which as you can see is ticking
up all the time as we speak and of
course getting us ever closer to the
global temperature rise of 1.5 degrees
we'll be discussing what role fossil
fuels will play in our future on our
daily climate show debate and tonight i
am joined by fatima ibrahim co-founder
of green new deal uk and bob ward from
the grantham research institute on
climate change and the environment that
is coming up for you in just a few
moments
and in some of today's other climate
news now and norway's conservative prime
minister ernest olberg has conceded
defeat after a general election campaign
that was dominated by climate change the
labour party is now in coalition talks
with as many as five other parties and
negotiations could have a major impact
in western europe's largest oil and gas
producer with the socialist left and
greens both opposing further exploration
and labor believing a withdrawal from
oil and gas production should be gradual
well there's been more extreme weather
today heavy rainfall look at this across
london caused severe delays cars and
buses struggled to cross london bridge
and some tube lines were closed as well
the met office has issued a yellow
warning for most of england saying the
midlands and northeast may see as much
as 70 millimeters of rain today
earlier this year an ipcc report on
climate change said that human influence
has likely increased the frequency of
extreme weather events including
flooding
and lab-grown woolly mammoths could be
in the arctic within six years
geneticists have already used gene
editing technology to splice frozen
woolly mammoth genes into the dna of
skin cells from an asian elephant and
they plan to create a genetically
modified elephant mammoth hybrid grown
in an artificial womb in a laboratory
scientists say that bringing back the
mammoth could revitalize arctic
grasslands slow the melting of
permafrost and increase natural carbon
capture
and neatly segueing from woolly mammoths
to the wombles of wimbledon common now
and the children's tv characters and eco
warriors don't forget from the 1970s are
being given a 21st century revamp as
part of the together for our planet
campaign ahead of the cop 26 climate
summit and skies katie spencer has more
[Music]
they were the original eco warriors
[Music]
not only have the wombles had a somewhat
questionable cgi makeover they've also
been given an important new job
making the nation aware of how to be
greener ahead of cop 26 part of a
government initiative ahead of
november's landmark climate summit
of course for those of a certain age
fond memories of wimbledon common come
flooding back but what about those who
don't remember uncle bulgaria
anyone under the age of 40 isn't really
going to get this
not even in the womble's hometown i
haven't heard of the wombles to be fair
no
are you aware that a climate conference
is happening no i think it's definitely
something that we should focus on
climate change for sure because we can
all feel it in the impact of it but i've
never heard of rumbles
while nobody would dare question the
womble's litter-picking skills not
everyone's convinced they're quite up to
leading the climate conversation
extinction rebellion's rush hour
blockade of the m25 on monday
demonstrated just how far some
protesters are prepared to go
for activists like this the government
initiative is a joke i think it's very
important that all of us collectively
look upon the mascots as the distraction
they're supposed to be
and carry on holding government's feet
to the fire and insisting they actually
make progress on measurable things that
we can judge them by well done orinoco
in a sky and you gov poll from earlier
this year 84 of those polled were
unclear about what cop 26 meant to those
that care about climate change the
government's messaging is a mess even
the wombles might struggle to clean up
it's been a very tiring morning katie
spencer sky news
now yesterday we brought you a special
report on one of africa's most forested
countries gabon and calls on the
international community to help with the
cost of conservation there well today we
can bring you the news of a 100 million
dollar commitment to protect areas in
africa
governments
across africa are literally desperate to
be part of the global solution to this
climate crisis
so we as african parks in the course of
last year
went through an analysis of all the
important protected areas and we believe
that there are 161 across the continent
that are absolutely essential to
conserving the
the continent's biodiversity these
landscapes are large landscapes and they
are intact ones and if they're not
intact we are responsible for restoring
wildlife so that it is intact and that
plays an incredibly important role uh in
terms of maintaining biodiversity in
terms of climate mitigation but equally
importantly in making sure that the
livelihoods of local people are also
sustained
there are literally tens hundreds of
thousands of people that live off these
systems that are entirely dependent on
their survival and therefore if they are
not looked after then there's something
where those very people perish as well
what's so clear with this climate crisis
equally important to the financing is
making sure that there are actors on the
ground that can be able to take the
actions that are necessary
to be able to revert it because if it's
only going to be
about talking and it's only going to be
about money
and it's not about action on the ground
then it's something where we're not
going to solve the problem
well don't go away because coming up
after the break we're going to be joined
by fatima ibrahim co-founder of green
new deal uk and bob ward from the
grantham research institute on climate
change and the environment and we'll be
discussing the role of fossil fuels plus
what is an effective climate change
emergency marketing campaign
basically this guy named drew we didn't
know each other but he had a tick tock
account and he was passing by these two
girls in the park basically
talking poorly about me and basically
saying that they wanted to plan a party
on a weekend that i was out of town so
that they didn't have to invite me in
the first place and from that he posted
a video and that video got about 16
million views or so
and it seemed like everyone and their
mother found out about it and knew about
it and it eventually got back to me i
saw it and we met up the next day and
talked about it and basically confirmed
that it was me overnight i got around
10 000 messages online
and every single person was like you
know what forget your old friends i
would love to be your friend i would
love to meet up with you and people from
new york where i live and from just
everywhere in the world uh was messaging
me this and so i was like why don't we
all just come together if we want the
same thing and we want to meet each
other and from that we all met up in one
place
and now
we've been doing it ever since and i do
all around the united states and
hopefully soon i'll be international i
think that's the best part about all of
this was that you know your mental
health can decline so much on social
media that this was an in-person
real life thing that people can attend
and kind of get offline and meet people
in real life versus just that whole
social media world and that's how this
kind of escalated my mental health and a
lot of others that you know the last
meetup in new york we had around 700
people and that was the most crazy i
mean i the fact that i could just post
something like that and that many people
show up and now i'm traveling around the
country in the world
hosting these meetups for people is just
absolutely incredible and i love to see
people meet others that you know months
later down the road they're sending me
photos and videos of them going on trips
with those people and i just think
that's so awesome that they would have
never probably crossed paths with them
in the first place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
wednesday is set to be a better day
although it will be rather cloudy first
thing overnight low cloud and fog will
lift to leave a largely dry day with
warm sunny spells there will be a few
showers around mainly for parts of
scotland northern ireland ireland and
the east coast of england
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high low levels of air pollution
are expected to continue on wednesday
and through the week
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news where earlier
in the program we were discussing the
countries committed to reducing new coal
power construction as well as norway's
election which was largely run on
climate change issues so the question is
is there a role for fossil fuels beyond
2050 well i'm joined now by fatima
ibrahim co-founder of the green new deal
uk and bob ward from the grantham
research institute on climate change and
the environment good to see both of you
fatima coming to you first do you think
there will still be demand for fossil
fuels in 30 years
i mean absolutely not if we're even
remotely interested in avoiding climate
disaster and ensuring a future that is
not just livable but promises
opportunity to thrive then there needs
to be no role for oil and gas and fossil
fuels beyond 2050 and waiting until 2050
is even a gamble the oil and gas
industry are betting on and wanting us
to bet our future on unproven
technologies of carbon capture and
storage so that they can stay in
business but the science is clear we
need to untether the global economy from
fossil fuels and we can transition in a
way that's just that provides security
for communities who are dependent on
these industries but we can only do that
if we start transitioning now and offer
an opportunity that delivers new green
jobs for these communities and what
about you bob do you think that that
pace of transition needs to be quicker
it certainly needs to be quicker but the
international energy agency earlier this
year was very clear if we want to get to
net zero emissions of greenhouse gases
by the middle of the century there
should be no
new development of coal oil and gas and
that's right across the world because
the reserves we already have are already
more than we can afford to burn if we
want to get to that 20 50 target so
every country including the uk should
not be exploring for more oil coal and
gas and it's unfortunate that the
current that the uk government has still
said that it wants exploration to
continue in the north sea yeah you're
quite right to bring up the iea there
and let's just look at that quote the
executive director of iea has said if
governments are serious about the
climate crisis there could be no new
investments in oil gas and coal from now
and that's a key distinction isn't it
fatima it's one thing using what you've
already got it's another thing pouring
money into into new fossil fuel
i mean absolutely and i think that's
where we see the hypocrisy of
governments who are telling us that we
need to take individual action that the
climate crisis is real and at the same
time we have the uk government who's
hosting a un climate conference one of
the most and the most important
international conference on climate and
is at the same time exploring the oil in
the north sea opening new coal mines in
cumbria um that just doesn't make sense
to anybody and i think that's
that's something i think we're all
concerned about and is creating a lot of
anxiety for people because we just see
that their words and their action is not
matching
all right well you mentioned the uk
government there of course hosting cop
26 there as you were saying at fatima
it's worth pointing out the government's
stance a government spokesman has said
we will continue to need oil and gas in
the coming years as it is still vital to
the production of many everyday
essentials bob what do you think do you
think that's damaging to our credibility
as host of cop26 when we say that
oil and gas is and coal is still vital
to our everyday needs
well it's clear that we're not going to
stop using fossil fuels overnight so it
will be a reduction over time but the
problem that the government has is that
it's basically saying do as we say not
as we do if it wants other countries to
commit to net zero by 2050 which is
quite rightly doing ahead of cop 26 and
it needs to lead by example by allowing
exploration to continue it risks
um
contributing to an oversupply of fossil
fuels which will depress the price and
make it more difficult to replace fossil
fuels it also means a lot of people are
going to lose money because my bet is we
are going to get to net zero by 2050 and
a lot of people who are betting on us
missing that target are going to lose
money by investing in fossil fuels it's
a bad bet to make yeah you snooze you
lose i suppose and fatima what do you
think do you think the uk can be
successful in persuading other countries
to stick to commitments when we're still
considering investments of our own
just briefly i mean no i don't i no i
don't think so and it's not just new
investments and new exploration the
government is propping up the fossil
fuel industry we subsidize the fossil
fuel industry 10.5 billion every year
the highest rate of subsidies in all of
europe so i don't know how this
government can call itself a leader when
it's it's backing up the fossil fuel
industry and really getting in the way
from us transitioning into a green
economy
all right there uh well as we get closer
of course to cop 26 we are seeing more
campaigns to encourage people to do
their bit from the government and
companies and not least as we brought
you earlier the wombles so how do you
market the fight against climate change
bob what do you think of campaigns like
that from the wombles do you think that
the public will take to that or might
they feel a bit patronized
well i think there might be some
children who are who are attracted by it
but for adults this is really about them
understanding that they can do their own
bit but they also have to play their
part in the political process the most
important single thing that any person
can do is write to their mp or local
councillor and say what are you doing to
tackle climate change it is putting
pressure on governments and on policy
makers to make the changes in policies
that is most important it cannot be done
just by voluntary action by individual
consumers yeah it's a key point isn't it
fatima i mean you
you sometimes wonder is it the public
that needs educating or does the
government or governments around the
world need to be clearer what their
policies and strategies are
i mean i could not agree more with bob
i'm sending you a virtual high five that
is the single most important thing
people can be doing because the truth is
in our country most people understand
climate change the the public is
unanimous in in their agreement that
there needs to be further action and
government-led action on climate change
it isn't the public it's clear that
we'll have to change the way that we
live over the next 30 years but most of
the action the majority of the action
needs to be coming from governments
to be leading we can't be expecting
individual choices uh to make up the
difference on climate change the wombles
is a great example i was too young
in the 70s they were educating people on
individual action to protect the
environment it's ironic to me that they
would be wheeled out 50 years later when
the government is still investing in new
coal and new oil to tell people about
individual action individual action is
not going to close the gap on the on
climate action it needs to be
government-led
yeah and there's an interesting
statistic isn't there bob that if you
look at people's intentions to do things
most people intend uh to do things that
are good for the environment but
actually the number of people who do
them it really drops off so there's
there's something to address isn't there
but in that in that movement from the
intention to the action
the majority of people clearly want to
do the right thing but quite often
what's holding them back is either that
they think that a bit being asked to do
an unfair amount or they're just finding
it very difficult and rather than
bringing back to life the wombles which
i'm very happy about i remember them
from the first time around frankly the
government should have speeded up the
publication of its net zero strategy and
the strategy that the treasury's
supposed to be looking at the net zero
review for how you help
uh families and households make the
transition how they can afford to buy a
new electric car and run it how they can
afford to replace their gas central
heating with low carbon alternatives
that's what the government must do it's
going to be difficult but that is what
it must focus on instead of bringing
back to life the warm balls i'm afraid
a lot of shade there for the womble so
i'm not sure whether it's appropriate
that i was planning to finish our
discussion now with a quote from who
else but great uncle bulgaria
if we will behave like wombles we can
make a difference to the health of our
country and our planet so we all know
what we need to do don't we fatima
ibrahim bob ward thank you very much for
your time tonight
well that's everything from us for today
joining me on the show tomorrow to
discuss all of those big climate issues
will be the founder and managing
director of seahorse international
isabella gornall and member of the
committee on climate change dame julia
king but do stay tuned for now coming up
on sky news tonight with dermot we'll
have more on what can be expected from
the prime minister's covert winter plan
after the uk's chief medical officers
have recommended vaccines for teenagers
but for now thanks for watching see you
tomorrow night
[Music]
you